last week on the show I recommended the
book predictably irrational by Dan
Ariely and some people I posted this to
my Instagram feed i'm on instagram at
david pakman and i hope you will follow
me on there i post some pretty clever
stuff sometimes some people were shocked
Pat that I actually was reading the book
that I recommended but that's my policy
I would not recommend a book that I
haven't read and people liking my
picture along with my pen my new thing
is when I read nonfiction I underline I
feel like my retention is higher when I
underline key parts of books I actually
owned the book that's my copy I know you
didn't you weren't skeptical that I
owned the book right no I was not and
also do you underline and then go back
to review some of the major parts of the
book yeah I write ooh sometimes though I
just get so into the next book that I
don't do that but yes and that I find
that that greatly increases my retention
of the information there so people
liking that also major major tuna
success I after a live stream recently I
said hey I've got to go make seared tuna
I've got to end the live stream and I
did do that and I posted it to my
Instagram account and people reacting
very very strongly to this pad and as
usual there's usually one or two vegans
anytime I post any animal product they
do try to encourage me to go vegan they
don't like when I post any animal
products to my Instagram but I did do
that and by and large people very very
excited about my seared tuna picture
here well it's a good thing first that
you fulfilled your live stream promise
yes I did make the tuna you may call me
a bad vegan or something for saying this
but I have a tough time relating to fish
really yeah I mean if there was anything
I would go back to it might be fish
interesting yeah I mean I've talked I
know many vegetarians who have added
shellfish and/or fish to their diets and
they don't seem to feel too bad about it
I must say right there are quite a lot
of pescetarians out there yes indeed so
please check it out I think that this
was a this is the first time I ever did
this the one mistake I did make
I used canola oil for searing and when
you have sesame seared tuna you usually
expect a more neutral or maybe like an
Asian type flavor and canola oil was not
the right oil if I did it again I think
maybe peanut oil is the oil I should be
using for searing tuna well I hope you
have another chance
I predict I will follow me on Instagram
David Pakman